is that the left believes all of society
must conform to them and particularly
you
must conform to them in every available
way and so they have taken over every
institution
every major institution of our society
uh it's hard to think of a more symbolic
a more symbolic move than the one that
was just made in the entertainment
industry
by dc comics so apparently according to
observer.com
shadow on acts has has a scoop author
tana hasey coates is now writing a
superman feature film produced by jj
abrams
as of now the project is shrouded in
mystery with no information provided on
whether the movie will be a sequel to
man of steel or complete
reboot without henry cavill deadline
says the film is a reboot
there's no director attached no plot
details available
code said to be invited into the dc
extended universe by warner brothers dc
films and bad robot is an honor i look
forward to meaningfully adding to the
legacy of america's most iconic
mythic hero he's listed in the thank you
credits of avengers infinity war end
game and black panther of course because
he penned some black panther and captain
america comic books
in which captain america gets woke
toby emmerich the warner brothers
chairman said his best-selling novel
between the world and me is
it's a non-fiction book lends itself to
a new and exciting way of viewing
the man of steel if by new and exciting
you mean that the guy
who used to be iconic for saying truth
justice in the american way
will now be systemic racism evil in the
american way
i mean this is what's going to happen
right you've taken
a superhero whose literal pitch is that
america is good and he is defending
american values
you're taking that and you're handing
that over to a guy who literally said
that he was watching 911 happen from the
top of an apartment building while
smoking marijuana i believe this is in
his memoir
and he suggested that he felt nothing
because of
the long history of racism in america
that's the person you're handing
superman over to
now again it's a private company
but they are wrecking a piece of
intellectual property
that was designed to be pro-america by
handing it to a person who really does
not like the foundational ideals of this
country
ta-nehisi coates is not a fan of the
foundational ideals of the country
he like nicole hannah jones believes
they were a lie when written he believes
they have never been truly acted out
and he believes that the fundamental
ideals of the country have to
fundamentally shift
and tanahasi coates is a is a a
slightly more soft-spoken ibrahmax
kennedy in terms of his actual politics
he is more social basically his idea is
that we need socialism in order to cure
racism he's kind of a bernie sanders
acolyte
along these lines but he's a racial
essentialist
he believes that that black and white
cannot understand each other
and you are handing superman the most
iconic american piece of intellectual
property there is
over the ta-nehisi codes so every
instant
every part of our culture is now being
militarized
on behalf of the woke left and then you
wonder why there is a blowback
there will be a blowback and it will be
egregious
final mode on this we've been updating
you on the
hubbub surrounding the bachelor you
remember that bachelor host chris
harrison who's the host for like the
last 25 years
has been replaced over the last 20 years
he's been replaced
temporarily right and he was replaced
because he had the temerity to say
that a contestant was originally
defended by the first black bachelor
because he was dating her
as not racist harrison said maybe we
should give her some grace and now he's
been canceled
from a show on which he's an executive
producer well now
now he has been replaced in the final on
the
beyond the rose episode whatever the
hell that is by a person named immanuel
akko who hosts a youtube series about
confronting racism
for the bachelor after the final rose
akko the host of the youtube series
uncomfortable conversations with the
black man announced on saturday he would
host the one hour special for the 25th
season
and akka will address the situation
head-on during the special because
clearly a dating show requires a person
who is a specialist in confronting
racism on youtube
sounds fantastic apparently the show has
placed a disclaimer on scene's films
before harrison
stepped aside the wrap reports that last
week's episode which featured footage of
harrison competing
on a celebrity edition of wheel of
fortune noted the scenes were filmed in
december we have to make sure that
everybody knows
that chris harrison has been canceled
and any appearance by chris harrison is
an appearance from the past
every institution every institution will
be militarized on behalf
of the woke left and you're either a
tool or an obstacle to them unless you
push back
hence the enduring popularity of donald
trump who is more of an obstacle
to the left than anybody else apparently
right this is the way that the left
views it facts don't care about your
feelings and it's a fact that the ben
shapiro show is the largest conservative
podcast in the nation
be sure to hit the subscribe button to
stay up to date on all of our content